gestrige wahltag hier in berlin wies für
viele menschen sie wollten wählen gehen
aber sie konnte nicht gelingen weil
dieser mann michael müller bürgermeister
von berlin sich überlegt hat acht
bundestagswahl da kann man doch auch
noch den marathon abhalten und dann ein
schönes wahlkampf und auf den letzten
metern sozusagen tatsächlich machen wie
er den startschuss gibt für den marathon
die gute nachricht ist die
marathonläufer kamen alle an die
menschen die ihr recht wahrnehmen
wollten zu wählen die kamen nicht alle
an denn die standen teilweise
stundenlang im berliner chaos fest oder
vor den wahllokalen und deswegen wollte
ich sie an diesem heutigen abend ganz
eindringlich waren sollte in den
nächsten monaten jemand der aussieht wie
michael müller und sich als
bundestagsabgeordneter es gibt auf sie
zu kommen und ihnen sagen er kann ihr
problem lösen eine gute idee sie sollten
ihm vertrauen kann ich ihnen als jemand
sagen der in dieser stadt lebt und
dieses chaos an dem heiligsten tag
unserer demokratie gäste mit erleben
sollte glauben sie ihm kein wort sie
haben es mit deutschland unfähigste max
bürgermeister zu tun der es tatsächlich
geschafft hat eine wahl in berlin zu
vermasseln
also ob es nun alles müller oder was war
ich weiß es nicht aber ich habe als ich
hier angekommen bin um an eurer
wahlberichterstattung teilzunehmen nach
zehn minuten gemerkt das kann nicht gut
gehen auf dem weg vom flughafen bis ins
studio waren da die ersten staus und das
wurde immer schlimmer und ich habe
gesagt es kann nicht sein dass die wahl
und der marathon laufen nebeneinander
funktionieren können und habe natürlich
dann entsprechend auch gemerkt es geht
nicht und es ging ja auch nicht ich hab
immer noch nicht kapiert wie das war ob
nach 18 uhr noch menschen wählen konnten
oder nicht aber die erregung war
berechtigt dass allein der verdacht
bestand dass menschen um 18.30 noch
nicht ihr wahlrecht ausüben konnten und
es ist glaube ich insgesamt ein berliner
problem man muss berlin sehen wie manche
berliner ist sehen nämlich wenn du zu
weit bist für diese stadt dann bleibt
doch woanders aber dass irgendwas
funktioniert ist nicht das berliner bild
also ich habe einen satz gehört ich bin
in münchen schon angenehmer fallen
worden als in berlin bedient und
das dass das mag so sein ich habe heute
im hotel 3 getroffen drei damen bin in
den letzten zwei tagen ihre handys
geklaut worden sind vom tisch
berlin ist felix magath ist das ein
gutes hotel da wundert man sich aber
dass die damen vor allem die dort
unterkommen ihre handys vermissen das
wundert nicht aber nichtsdestotrotz eine
davon war die familie bereits erwähnte
masseurin die vietnamesen die
vietnamesen die darüber schimpft dass
ihre eltern nicht nachholen kann während
alle
rumänen oder was auch immer ihr dann die
dürfen nach berlin kommen schau dir dann
die handy ist also da hat das schloss
sich für sie der kreis nichtsdestotrotz
also berlin ist offensichtlich was ganz
besonderes man muss es mögen ich bin
morgen wieder weg in berlin werden
berlin lebt hat ja ein ganz besonderes
verhältnis zu straßensperren berlin hat
nicht viel berlin hat aber die schönsten
und größten und umfangreichsten
straßensperrungen der welt es war
tatsächlich nach meinem empfinden
leichter von west nach ost zu kommen als
die mauer noch stand als jetzt in der
zeit nur michael müller regierender
bürgermeister war und für jedes
partikularinteressen
sofort die achse dicht macht die durch
diese stadt wird und es kommt glaube ich
aus einem ganz bestimmten menschenbild
heraus nämlich aus dem menschenbild dass
man gegen 14 15 16 uhr aufsteht dann zum
späten geht sich kurz zwei dosen
schultheiß holt dann ein projekt macht
und dann langsam frühstück geht und
alles so müsse im bereich von 1 2 blocks
stattfindet dass menschen wie du
vielleicht in die stadt rein fahren
müssen weil sie von woanders kommen weil
sie was zu tun hatten dann vielleicht
noch werden wollen sagt 17 uhr bin ich
in der stadt das schaffe ich dieses
ganze menschenbild da arbeitet
vielleicht jemand da hat vielleicht
jemand was anderes zu tun als auf der
straße des 17 juni entweder zu roller
bleiben oder wie gesagt für ihre
partikularinteressen zu demonstrieren
dass kommt tatsächlich oder ist in den
letzten jahren der berliner regierung
und verwaltung in keiner weise
vorgekommen und das ergebnis haben wir
gestern gesehen wir wissen ja auch nicht
wie viele menschen nicht wählen konnten
das gehört ja auch zu bedienen dass alle
menschen die vermutlich nicht wählen
wollten jetzt behaupten sie konnten
nicht wählen man wird es niemals
erfahren wir wissen nur tatsächlich
unzählige menschen konnten gestern nicht
ihre stimme abgeben aber also bei allem
respekt zum einen bauer wird zu wählen
sie hier langsam vor sich nein bei allem
respekt vor dir also machen wir jetzt
finde ich immer schwierig aber das einem
lakritze über die mauer das ist ein
fahrrad sowie die berliner unfähigkeit
zu regieren da stimmt und tatsächlich
wir haben gerade lustig lustig
aufgezogen aber es ist einfach nicht
witzig also wenn diese dieser gedanke
vom fenster berlin der ist schon so oft
beschrieben worden er ist auch so
abgedroschen aber er stimmt er stimmt
immer wieder ich meine wie kann man
darauf kommen an einem wochenende den
marathon in dieser stadt stattfinden zu
lassen und es ist ja auch etwas ich
meine die frage ist ja durchaus
berechtigt landet das jetzt vor
gerichten und wenn es am ende vor
gericht trat vor gerade diese hat diese
warenbestand wird diese wahl wiederholt
wird frau die am ende in dieser stadt
dann nach vorne liegen gegen die grünen
fahren also sind so viel implikationen
dabei auch auf die bundesebene also ich
weiß nicht das ist es ist ja das ist
lustig aber es ist nicht lustig das ist
bisher glaube ich übrigens auch noch
überhaupt nicht geklärt was ist
eigentlich mit menschen die ihre stimme
für die bundestagswahl abgeben wollten
ja es gab dann am ende die die
aufteilung ist auch das finde ich auch
das wunderbare das ist 24 stunden später
noch nicht geklärt ist also was daraus
folgt ich glaube habe fast den verdacht
alle wissen da folgt was ganz
furchtbares draußen nämlich so ähnlich
wie du sagst
grundsätzliche fragen gestellt ist das
dann ein gültiges ergebnis
um das zu erreichen müsste man beweisen
können dass die ergebnisse in den
betroffenen wahllokalen keinen einfluss
auf das gesamtergebnis garten das ist
aber bei so einem knappen rennen relativ
schwierig aber auch das wird nach
berliner art in aller ruhe nach dem
ich fand den tagesablauf so schön also
irgendwo zwischen schulter ist und
frühstück gegen 18 uhr wahrscheinlich
besprochen wenn die berliner behörden um
18 uhr überhaupt noch offen wer also es
ist wirklich nicht witzig und was mich
gestern schon bedrückt hat sind die
bilder die da entstanden sind die ja um
die welt gehen es ist der wahltag in
deutschland und es gibt kommt zu
unregelmäßigkeiten in wahllokalen so ist
dann die nachrichten sprache diese
botschaft kommt normalerweise aus
ländern in denen man so was nie
beobachtet wo man normalerweise er
eigentlich muss man jetzt hat die idee
kommen ihn künftig wahlbeobachter zu
schicken um rauszufinden ob es da mit
rechten dingen zugeht es wäre es ist
verrückt und es wäre lustig wenn sie
nicht der ganzen stadt so gemäss wären
berlin ist auch die stadt wo leute
vorschlagen dass die drogendealer im
görlitzer park an dem fußballturnier
teilnehmen können weil es sozial
ungerecht ist dass die nur darum steht
also er ist erhält eine verrückte stadt
der witz ist irgendwann schalen und
irgendwann wird es ernst und das war
gestern ja und vor allem dieses failed
state was du erwähnt hast das erleben
wir dann ja an solchen tagen die ja auch
irgendwie an absurdität kaum noch zu
überbieten sind aber es zeigt sich ja in
den abgelegeneren und weniger coolen
nachbarschaft in dieser stadt in
hellersdorf in marzahn im märkischen
viertel in den in den sozial schwächeren
stadtteilen der hauptstadt des
viertreichste landes der welt zeigt sich
dieses feld stato ja jeden tag ja ich
war vor ein paar monaten mal bei der
arche zu besuch großartige
bemerkenswerte bewundernswerte menschen
die sich darum sozial schwache kinder
kümmern da gibt es inzwischen arche
tourismus nennen wir das da ziehen
menschen nach hellersdorf weil sie
wissen da ist die arche und da wird
fabelhaft auf unsere kinder aufgepasst
ja das ist inzwischen das ist halt der
alltag in berlin also das finde ich ist
für mich einfach ab und und das zeigt
sich halt genau in solchen in solchen
entgleisungen gäste aller verrückteste
ist und jetzt sind wir alle demokraten
dass es den menschen in berlin
jedenfalls einer großen anzahl von
menschen in berlin ja genau so gefällt
wie es ist das ist das bestätigen
mehrere regierungen ja die
verantwortlich sind für dieses chaos was
wir jetzt
juni zieren und kritisiert das finde ich
wirklich faszinierend also
wahrscheinlich sind die wir alle
zulässig für berlin der die berliner
lieben also ich hab da gestern noch eine
einfache und das war das sind hier die
kleinen dingen die verloren gehen es gab
nicht nur den marathon dort wo ich
gewählt habe war auch noch ein
straßenfest und das straßenfest fand auf
einer straße statt die sozusagen die
verbindungsachse zwischen zwei bereichen
in dem wahlbezirk war das heißt wenn man
diese
verbindungsachse mit dem auto überqueren
wollte dann ist man nicht zu seinem
wahllokal gekommen da frage ich mich
tatsächlich wer kommt darauf an
wahltagen die zugangsstraßen zu
wahllokal ich sehe das ist das kleinste
ist einzig bin total bei euch und das
ist furchtbar leid wie man die marathon
darauf legen kann aber ich bin der
festen überzeugung wenn man wählen will
schafft man es auch und ja wir sollten
den deutschen die oder allen menschen
das auf dem silbertablett servieren zu
wählen absolut damit wirklich jeder
macht aber zb ich wusste irgendwie am
dienstag kann sich nicht sonntag
düsseldorf sein kann wo ich erlebe weil
ich hier bin dann habe ich briefwahl
beantragen das war sogar noch dienstag
möglich meine schwester sogar erst
mittwoch gemacht derweil wir wollten es
dann zusammen mach mal für unsere fans
werden so ein familien ding weil ich
jetzt brief er machen muss dass meine
schwester auf briefwahl und dann habt
ihr ambri folgen ja genau bei den sabres
die familien sieht man ja trotzdem was
wenn auch etwas besonderes auf jeden
fall für meine familie ich muss sagen du
hast gewählt in berlin julian am sonntag
auf sich ich habe mich durch die durch
die zahlreichen chinas abstellen muss
ich auch sagen ich finde natürlich ist
es ganz schlimm was da passiert ist ich
habe trotzdem für niemanden verständnis
der sonntag nicht seine stimme gegeben
hat weil es gibt man kann auch morgen
schon zehn gehen auch berliner
mentalität man muss nicht also um 17 uhr
oder um 17 uhr 45 gehen ich war schön
aber es können natürlich nicht alle
menschen haben wir einfach die kondition
drei stunden lang in einer schlange zu
stehen insofern manche menschen konnten
ist einfach weil ich ja nie wie sonst
wäre der spruch entstanden wer die wahl
hat hat die qual ganz genau gesehen
haben digitalen machen sollten also
alles digital möglich wieder freuen sich
besonders die russen du musst in baden
baden werden die länger ich habe da
3-rückstand 3 rollatoren und sonst war
niemand da
[Musik]